[Música]
son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna seguimos comentándoles
los principales hechos del día Les
agradecemos su sintonía y vamos con los
titulares de esta jornada
el partido republicano llegó a la
esperada cifra de 218 escaños lo que les
da la mayoría en la cámara de
representantes la cámara baja del
Congreso entre tanto los demócratas
alcanzan 200 días representantes el
recién confirmado líder de los
republicanos Kevin mccarthy sucedería
Nancy pelosi en el tercer cargo de mayor
importancia política en Estados Unidos
Tenemos reporte
Polonia y la otan defendieron que el
misil de fabricación rusa que impactó
suelo polaco fue disparado por Ucrania
pero añadieron que la responsabilidad
finales de Moscú por la guerra que Libra
en territorio ucraniano Washington apoya
la versión mientras que haya lanzado el
proyectil
por una calurosa bienvenida fue recibido
el presidente electo de Brasil Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva en la conferencia
climática de Naciones Unidas en Egipto
el mandatario se pronunció a favor de
proteger la amazonía y señaló que es una
clave para que exista seguridad
climática en el planeta
[Música]
[Aplausos]
damos inicio en Estados Unidos porque
los republicanos consiguieron llegar a
los 218 escaños adjudicados en la cámara
de representantes la anhelada cifra que
garantiza obtener la mayoría de esta
forma los rojos se hacen con la cámara
baja del congreso en donde los
demócratas obtienen por ahora 210
escaños el recuento de votos de las
elecciones de medio término realizadas
el pasado 8 de noviembre se ha extendido
por más de una semana
a esta hora conectamos con Cristóbal
Vázquez corresponsal de France 24 en
Washington Cristóbal que implica que los
republicanos se queden con el control de
la cámara pero los demócratas tengan el
control del senado con las cifras
actuales
Pues eso implica que habrá un bloqueo
legislativo es decir los republicanos sí
podrían llamar a investigaciones si
podrían llamar a investigar a
indagatoria a demócratas y a otros
políticos en el país y podrían avanzar
con su agenda política agenda política
sin embargo que a la hora de ellos
presentar proyectos de ley Pues
Posiblemente sea bloqueada por un senado
de mayoría
demócrata podrían pasar por ejemplo en
esta agenda demócrata que tienen los
republicanos
se incluye temas por ejemplo como
recortes en el gasto del gobierno se
incluye también esta gente republicana
temas como avanzar en la exploración
petrolera y también en Pues implementar
otra vez códigos Fiscales psicológicos
tributarios que venían de la época del
ex presidente Donald Trump sin embargo
Pues esta agenda será posiblemente
bloqueada por esa mayoría demócrata
Aunque tienen entonces la posibilidad de
investigar tienen entonces la
posibilidad de llamar indagatoria no van
a poder avanzar mucho su agenda Dado que
los demócratas tienen el senado Este es
el fin también de posiblemente Nancy
pelosi como presidenta de la cámara de
representantes teniendo en cuenta que
pues ya fue aprobado de forma interna el
nuevo presidente de la cámara de
representantes Bueno ya usted lo estaba
mencionando y sabíamos que si se lograba
esta mayoría republicana lo más probable
era que queden mccarthy renfe
reemplazará a Nancy pelosi como
presidente de la cámara de
representantes que falta entonces para
que mccarthy sea confirmado
Pues ahora una brotación en pleno es
decir los
435 congresistas nuevos se reunirán la
primera semana de enero para confirmar a
Kevin mccarthy tendrán que Kevin
Mccartney asegurar al menos 218 votos
para Pues confirmarse en el cargo de
presidente de la cámara de
representantes y este punto es
importante porque la votación interna
del partido republicano
188 republicanos apoyaron a Kevin
mccarthy en contra de la persona que el
que espera el contrincante para quedarse
también en la silla de presidente de la
cámara de representantes y 38 38
congresistas republicanos votaron en
contra de Kevin mccarthy y esto muestra
que nuevamente hay una división interna
en el partido republicano pero muestra
que Kevin mccarthy no se puede dar el
lujo de perder muchas sillas en esta
votación en plenaria muchas años
teniendo en cuenta además que los
demócratas claramente van a votar en
contra de Kevin Mccartney en contra de
su candidatura ya confirmada Por los
republicanos Pero entonces pues le queda
un trabajo bastante arduo que hoy
mccarthy en las próximas semanas para
asegurar estos 218 votos que necesita
para poder ser confirmado como
presidente de la cámara de
representantes Cristóbal usted muchas
gracias por esta ampliación estamos
pendientes de lo que ocurra en Estados
Unidos y justamente seguimos en este
país porque una corte Federal concedió
este miércoles al gobierno un periodo de
cinco semanas para prepararse antes de
la suspensión del título 42 una norma
que permitió la expulsión de migrantes y
regulares por motivos sanitarios durante
la pandemia de Kobe 19 y que aún está
vigente para analizar esta información
conectamos con Ariel Ruiz experto en
políticas públicas del instituto de
políticas migratorias con sede en
Washington DC Bienvenido a France 24
cuando Joe biden llegó a la presidencia
una de las Grandes esperanzas fue el del
título 42 una de sus promesas qué ha
pasado en estos dos años de gobierno
Bueno una de las cosas que intentó el
presidente pero todavía no podía actuar
en ello es quitar el título 42 para que
personas que pueden llegar a la frontera
tengan una oportunidad de pedir asilo en
el país si bien lo mencionó como una de
sus campañas al final el día
republicanos y algunos demócratas le
impidieron hacer esto y por eso las
Cortes y tribunales se han se han
documentado en este caso lo que sucedió
ayer Es que la corte dijo que este tipo
de proceso de título 42 no era justo y
tampoco es necesario para las personas y
las personas que llegan a la frontera
pero también para la política del país
lo cual ahora nos regresa a un periodo
en 2019 cuando las personas que llegaron
la frontera podían pedir asilo y muchas
de ellas también cuando entran al país
tendrían que seguir retomando su caso
para hacer para quedarse en el país o
para ser deportados eso va a ser lo que
podemos esperar para los siguientes
meses que llegan y como bien lo
mencionaron empezaría esto empezando a
mediados de diciembre
este bloqueo del título 42 puede atraer
a más migrantes irregulares a la
frontera sur de Estados Unidos esto en
medio de los esfuerzos del gobierno
vayan Pues por contener los flujos
migratorios
es un argumento que hacemos escuchado
mucho Y claro que la migración y los
migrantes responden no solamente a
motivaciones económicas o en sus países
de origen pero también a las
motivaciones y cambios en la política de
Estados Unidos en este caso Podemos
esperar que sí en efectivo en los
primeros meses que vemos por ejemplo de
aquí a a marzo veremos a lo mejor algún
aumento en el flujo migratorio en la
frontera ya que más personas buscarán
entrar de manera irregular y tan
siquiera pedir de esa manera asilo en el
país pero también tenemos que entender
que este tipo de flujo que estamos
viendo en la frontera tiene que ver más
con falta de acceso a tener aún así uno
en un caso de asilo en el país que
ahorita no existe si tuviésemos mejores
controles para poder procesar Estos
tipos de casos en la frontera es
importante más rápido podríamos ver
quién es de estas personas pueden
encontrar al país y cuáles tienen que
ser o podrían ser deportadas a otro país
el título 42 no iba originalmente a
ciudadanos venezolanos pero desde el
acuerdo con México este acuerdo reciente
este grupo de migrantes está en la mira
cómo está su situación en estos momentos
este bloqueo los impacta de alguna
manera
sí efectivamente este acuerdo que se dio
A mediados del mes pasado en octubre se
enfocaba en incluir ahora Venezuela en
este tipo de nacionalidades que pueden
ser repatriadas a México desde Estados
Unidos este esta edición de ya no
continuar con el título 42 impacte
directamente a esa población venezolana
que ahora podrá otra vez llegar la
frontera pedir asilo y algunos de ellos
entran al país vuelvo a recalcar no
solamente porque lleguen en la frontera
y sean procesados para ingresar
significa que se van a quedar muchos de
ellos Incluyendo a otras personas por
ejemplo cubanas nicaragüenses tendrán
que terminar su proceso de asilo en
determinación en los tribunales y de ahí
determinar se pueden quedar o no antes
de esto lo que hemos visto desde que
empezó el programa de marzo de 2020
hemos visto que casi 2.4 millones de
personas han sido devueltas o expulsadas
bajo este proceso de título 42 y cabe
mencionar que no solamente son
nacionalidades mexicanas
americanas que también van a ser
afectadas por esto el señor Ruiz a usted
muchas gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros en francés 24
Gracias cambiamos de tema porque la otan
y el gobierno de Varsovia título propio
defendieron que Rusia es el responsable
de la guerra en Ucrania y también es
culpable indirecto del misil que cayó
Este martes en territorio polaco cerca
de la frontera con Ucrania no obstante
junto con la Casa Blanca defendieron la
hipótesis que indica que los misiles que
dejaron dos fallecidos fueron disparados
desde Ucrania
un misil cae el martes en Polonia y mata
a dos personas las primeras sospechas
van contra Rusia pero el presidente
polaco lo descartó el miércoles en este
momento no tenemos ninguna prueba de que
este misil haya sido disparado por la
parte rusa mientras que hay muchos
indicios hay muchas posibilidades de que
se trate de un misil utilizado en la
defensa antimisino ante el encendido de
las sirenas por una posible escalada Más
allá de Ucrania Rusia se defiende
las fotografías de los restos
encontrados en el pueblo de chebulube
Fueron identificadas inequívocamente por
expertos militares de rusos como
fragmentos de un misil antiaéreo de un
sistema de defensa aérea ucraniano s-300
pero horas más tarde el presidente
ucraniano en bolodimir cellensky
insistió en que fue Rusia
no tengo ninguna duda de que no fue
nuestro misil ni nuestro ataque no tengo
motivos para dudar de ellos
Estados Unidos y la otan se posicionan
con Polonia el misil proviene de
recompensa aérea ucraniana pero la culpa
de Rusia
todavía estamos recopilando información
pero no hemos visto nada que contradiga
la evaluación preliminar del presidente
dudas de que esta explosión
probablemente fue el resultado de un
misil de defensa aérea ucraniano que
desafortunadamente cayó en Polonia y
cualesquiera que sean las conclusiones
finales el mundo sabe que Rusia tiene
responsabilidad final por este incidente
lo más probable es que se trate de
sistemas de defensa aéreo o misiles
ucranianos Pero nuevamente Esto no es
culpa de Ucrania Rusia es responsable de
lo que sucedió ayer en Polonia
los temores de que el conflicto escalé
sean aliviado pero desde Ucrania
insisten en una investigación en terreno
vamos ahora a hablar del presidente
electo de Brasil Luis Ignacio lulada
Silva que pronunció inesperado discurso
en la cop 27 Lula seguro que devolver a
su país a la escena internacional para
luchar contra la crisis ambiental y las
desigualdades en el mundo al mismo
tiempo criticó el gobierno del
ultraderechista Yair bolsonaro en el que
según dijo hubo un enorme retroceso en
temas ambientales
entre aplausos y cantos
así fue la recepción del presidente
electo de Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva en la con 27 el izquierdista
pronunció un discurso en el que dejó
algo claro Brasil está de vuelta en la
escena internacional Un regreso en el
que según Lula se luchará contra el
cambio climático y las desigualdades a
nivel mundial y del que cobrará la deuda
pendiente de los países desarrollados
con los países más vulnerables 100.000
millones de dólares que aseguró aún no
se han pagado
Los acuerdos Tienen que salir del papel
y para eso es imprescindible volver
disponibles los recursos para que los
más pobres puedan enfrentar las
consecuencias de los problemas creados
en buena medida por los países más ricos
de una manera desproporcionada que está
afectando a los más vulnerables
en la con 27 Lula mostró su voluntad de
desmarcarse de su predecesor ya ir por
sunaru y reactivar los esfuerzos por
luchar contra la deforestación que llegó
a máximos en los últimos 15 años durante
el mandato del ultraderechista
no hay seguridad climática para el mundo
sin una amazonía protegida
el resultado de las elecciones
brasileñas dependía no solo la paz y el
bienestar del pueblo brasileño sino
también la supervivencia de la amazonía
y por lo tanto la supervivencia de
nuestro planeta
la creación de una cumbre de los países
amazónicos fue uno de los primeros
anuncios a nivel internacional que hizo
Lula desde su elección en octubre al
mismo tiempo esbozó varias líneas que
seguirá durante su mandato
luchar contra los crímenes ambientales y
crear un Ministerio de los pueblos
originarios así llegamos al final de
esta misión de directo América a ustedes
Les agradecemos su sintonía los Vamos a
continuar con nosotros que ya llega a
nuestra periodista Natalia Ruiz con
Francia en foco feliz noche para todos
[Música]